SPEAKER 1: Oceanic
ecosystems are
threatened by a lack of
science-based fishery
management today.
For example, 34% of the world's
major commercial fish species
are overfished.
And more than $23
billion of seafood
is stolen annually from the sea
through illegal and unregulated
fishing, also causing
habitat destruction.
This is why a free website
called GlobalFishingWatch.org
was launched by
Google in partnership
with other organizations,
such as Oceana and SkyTruth,
in 2016.
To monitor fishing
activity globally
and make it transparent
to anyone online for free.
They use satellite technology,
cloud computing, and machine
learning in order to
find navigation patterns,
using a public signal received
by a GPS-like device called
the Automatic Identification
System or AIS, used
by the vessels in the sea.
You can imagine tracking 60
million points from vessels
worldwide quickly grows
into a big data problem.
So let's dive in and see
how to approach the problem.
Thanks to data, today we can
understand our natural world
with far greater
richness than ever
before by orders of magnitude.
This now empowers us to
build amazing apps that
can help us solve complex social
and environmental challenges.
And so in this series,
let's build an app together.
Meet Brian, who's worked at
Google for over 14 years.
He's a co-founder of
Global Fishing Watch.
BRIAN SULLIVAN: So to understand
why we did Global Fishing
Watch, we first really
had to understand
what the state of fishing at a
global level was in the world.
And the stats were
pretty sobering.
So when you think of something
like a tuna or a swordfish,
about 90% of that
species has disappeared
in the last generation or two.
And when you look at fish that
actually end up on a plate,
you're talking about how about
one in five, or 20% of those,
is considered IUU, so Illegal,
Unreported, or Unregulated.
And then when you finally
look at fisheries themselves,
they say that about
90% plus of them
were either at
capacity, overfished,
or trying to recover.
So when we started
Global Fishing Watch,
I like to say that it wasn't
possible three years earlier.
It was barely feasible
when Global Fishing Watch
was starting.
And now we wonder how
we didn't do it sooner.
And from a pure technology and
machine learning perspective,
our first versions of this
were rough heuristics.
It gave us a rough sense
of where a vessel might be.
And now machine learning
has evolved so far so
that we're able to not
only see whether or not
a vessel's fishing based
on how it's moving.
We're also able to differentiate
the type of fishing
that they're doing.
And so we continue to stay on
the cutting edge of machine
learning as it applies to the
fundamental conservation issues
or policy issues that we're
addressing with fishing.
SPEAKER 1: I love this project,
and definitely recommend
leveraging all the extensive
work the amazing Global Fishing
Watch teams have made
accessible on their website
as well as on their
beautiful YouTube channel.
BRIAN SULLIVAN:
So within Google,
I feel really lucky
that I get to work
on a team whose focus is to make
a positive change in the world
from an environmental
or societal perspective.
I honestly don't
think this would
have been possible
without Google
willing to invest in
something like fishing,
that isn't something you would
normally associate with Google.
At the end of the day,
it was about making
information universally
accessible and digestible,
very much part of our mission.
So to actually build
Global Fishing Watch,
we really used the full suite of
Google Cloud platform products.
Fundamentally, BigQuery
was the only tool
that was out there
that was enabling
us to look at billions and
billions of these ship position
reports.
And be able to look and them
not only over time, but also
spatially.
Just storing that alone
was the type of thing
that didn't scale to
a lot of other areas.
But then the ability
to go in and analyze it
in near real time, so
it enables an analyst
to kind of see how
this is unfolding
and tweak their
algorithms as necessary.
SPEAKER 1: And if you're curious
about how to make a time series
classification app that includes
latitude and longitudinal data,
let me give you a quick tour
using Google Cloud tools.
Let's start with a snapshot
of the products used.
First up is Apache Beam, which
is an open source library
that you run a Google's data
processing service, called
Data Flow, to create
two data sets needed
for machine learning.
One is for training and
the other for evaluation.
Next is TensorFlow Keras,
which is a high level API
library used to define a
machine learning model,
where we then
train in Vertex AI.
As for the data, we get this
from Global Fishing Watch's
GitHub repository.
It includes a ship's
unique identifier
called Maritime Mobile Service
Identity or MMSI, which
was broadcasted at different
times along with its lat,
long coordinates,
distance from shore
and port, its speed,
and its course
at different times of the day.
The irregularity in time in
which the data's collected then
requires us to transform it into
even hourly intervals, which
we call time steps.
The model uses a
one-dimensional,
Fully Convolutional
Network, FCN.
Because it enables us to feed a
variable number of hourly time
steps.
It assesses patterns in
the vessel's movements
within each window of time.
And as an output, it labels
whether it is fishing or not.
Now, for this type of
supervised learning,
we need training data
that has fishing labels.
And Global Fishing Watch
performed the labor
of love of manually
investigating and then
producing over 140,000
label time ranges.
And for context,
even though that's
a tiny subset relative
to the massive data set,
it's more than enough
to build a model.
Next, we create the
training and evaluation
data sets in parallel
via an Apache Beam
pipeline running on Data Flow.
Now, from a data
preparation standpoint,
we ideally want to feed
the model raw data that
resembles what we
get from the field
in order to get predictions
as new data arrives.
Next, we define the
model using Keras,
and train it on Vertex AI, which
is an API with a client library
and user interface that enables
you to train, save, deploy,
and request predictions.
After our model is trained,
we save it in Cloud Storage
and can either load it
into a Python app, deploy
it as an endpoint in Vertex AI,
or in a web app using Cloud Run
Serverless infrastructure.
We visualize the predictions
in a free Jupyter
notebook called Colab using
a map visualization library.
We can see the ship
moving and changing color
when it's fishing
and when it's not,
according to the predictions.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
So what's next?
Well, in this video description
is a detailed blog post,
some friendly links,
and most importantly,
an awesome lab built in
collaboration with my peer
David, which contains all
the code needed so you do not
have to write a single line
and can interact with the map
yourself.
If you found this content
helpful, by the way,
you can subscribe or leave
a comment on other AI
for Good use cases
you have in mind.
And community,
before we end, I'm
going to leave you with Brian's
fun fact about the project.
BRIAN SULLIVAN: It's really
shaped kind of the way I go out
and the way I interact
with nature now.
And it just makes me really
kind of figure out what's around
the corner for the next thing.
And there's so many
incredible stories
of seeing what happens when
you simply put information
in the hands of others, and
how they go on and take that
into other areas.
[MUSIC PLAYING]